this video was made possible by class -
central.com slash Pakman where you can
find tens of thousands of lectures from
the world's best universities get
started by clicking the link under this
video in this episode of the
pseudoscience miniseries I'm going to
talk about one of the most widely
practiced types of alternative medicine
and a total and complete pseudoscience
homeopathy time and again since its
inception homeopathy has failed to be
proven effective for any type of medical
condition many comprehensive studies
have shown that when patients receive
homeopathic treatments exclusively their
health only improves due to the placebo
effect or because of normal recovery
that would have occurred anyway called
return to the mean homeopaths people who
practice homeopathy say that the
foundational principle of their
philosophy is that quote like cures like
as the National Center for homeopathy
says on its website a medicine can cure
a sick person if it can cause a similar
sickness in a healthy person and they
give an example if you peel an onion
your eyes burn they itch and they water
you might also have a runny nose and
begin to sneeze if you had similar
symptoms during a cold or allergy attack
like a runny nose watery eyes and
sneezing a homeopathic micro dose of the
remedy Allium CEPA red onion would help
your body heal itself don't make the
mistake of overthinking this because
there's nothing to overthink homeopathy
is as nonsensical as it sounds here and
along the same lines another common
homeopathic remedy is to give small
doses of certain types of coffee to
someone suffering from insomnia
homeopathy posits that a substance that
causes a symptom in a healthy person
will alleviate the same symptom in an
unhealthy person if given in small doses
and that is homeopathy second premise
that the dose has to be small and
diluted in order to work and in fact
homeopathy asserts that the more diluted
the remedy is the more effective it will
be
this also contradicts everything we know
about how the
than science work the tradition in
homeopathy is to dilute the remedy with
either alcohol or distilled water if the
remedy is a solid that can't be
dissolved in water like seashells for
example which is a common homeopathic
medicine the solid should be ground up
and mixed with lactose which is the
sugar found in milk what is it about
alcohol distilled water or lactose that
make the remedies more effective nothing
but homeopaths referred to this process
of diluting remedies as-siq Eugen and
they say that the process of securing is
what releases the remedies quote vital
energy and the more the substance is
diluted the more powerful it becomes
which of course is illogical on its face
because under almost all circumstances
diluting a substance cannot actually
make it more potent in most homeopathic
concoctions the original substance is
actually diluted to the point of being
essentially absent from the mixture
altogether meaning that homeopathy often
contains no active ingredients for
example one common method of securing is
to combine one part substance with 10 to
the 24th power pure water in which case
there is only a 60% chance that the
resulting mixture will contain even one
molecule of the original substance but
the founder of homeopathy Samuel
Hahnemann recommended that most remedies
be diluted three times more than that
and Hahnemann a German physician
developed homeopathy in 1796 this was
before science discovered the concept of
standard atomic weight which taught us
that if a substance is diluted enough in
another substance the diluted substance
will physically disappear from the
mixture so Hahnemann of course didn't
know anything about that but today we
don't really have the same excuse
because we now know about science and
homeopathy ignores very simple
well-established chemistry facts for
example a popular homeopathic remedy for
treating flu symptoms is to combine one
part duck liver with ten to the four
hundredth power parts of Lac
it's mass produced in tablet form it's
actually pretty popular in France and it
is a total and complete sham according
to homeopathy the mixture has to be
exactly one part duck-liver
to ten to the four hundredths parts
power parts lactose and it's a strict
formula however there are only about 10
to the 80th power atoms in the
observable universe therefore for
someone to consume one molecule of
duck-liver from this mixture they would
have to eat a cube that is ten to the
55th power light-years wide which is
much much wider than the universe itself
basically the concept of this
homeopathic duck-liver
lactose mix is so ridiculous that it's
difficult to describe just how
ridiculous it is in a way that the human
mind can even comprehend so whether it's
commercially produced or homemade it
either contains 100% lactose and no duck
liver or it contains way more duck liver
than is actually prescribed by
homeopathy some manufacturers have
gotten away
selling pure lactose and only putting
duck liver in Latin on the label so as
to not be legally liable for promising
that it even contains any duck liver at
all homeopaths believed that solvents
like water and lactose are able to
retain what they refer to as a quote
memory of the substance that is being
dissolved even when the substance is
dissolved to the point of there being no
mathematical possibility that a single
molecule of the substance remains in the
solution and although it violates the
elementary principles of chemistry in
the ways that I've explained this
concept of quote water memory is a key
mechanism by which homeopathy supposedly
works so the pseudo science behind how
homeopathy works doesn't hold up but
still we should ask the question does it
actually work in people well what's
important to know is that people can
experience positive results after
receiving any kind of unscientific
treatment meeting with anyone including
a homeopathy to talk about your medical
issue and undergo
any sort of treatment it is enough to
put many people in a better state of
mind about their health this is by way
of the placebo effect and many people
just don't realize how powerful that
placebo effect can be it's been proven
that your thoughts and emotions can have
a very significant impact on what goes
on in the rest of your body organs
regulated by the nervous system like
your heart your stomach your lungs
they're directly linked to your brain
and so they are very susceptible to
placebo a 2011 review of neurobiological
findings published in Nature reports
that merely visiting a homeopathic
practitioner is easily enough to change
the chemistry and circuitry of the
patient's brain even if the practitioner
administers no treatment whatsoever that
would otherwise be medically effective
and this makes people feel better
there's a 2013 review of studies
examining homeopathy --zz relationship
with placebo published in the Royal
Society of Medicine which explains quote
we can attribute meaning to therapeutic
encounters with culturally sanctioned
authority figures and we can use our
attachment to such figures to generate
hope for recovery the context of the
clinical encounter and the relationship
between the healer and the patient are
imbued with meaning and enshrined in
ritual so when you visit someone whose
treatment methods you believe are
effective just meeting with them it can
make you feel better even if the actual
treatment they give isn't medically
sound but as far as homeopathy actual
effectiveness in treating medical
conditions in and of itself the burden
of proof lies with the homeopathy
but all suppose that evidence for the
effectiveness of homeopathy has proven
time and again to be a result of
insufficient methodology and meanwhile
there's plenty of evidence pointing to
homeopathy being completely bunk
rigorous homeopathy trials exist with
high methodology standards and they have
unanimously shown that the practice is
useless
when the studies are done properly under
double-blind conditions with a control
group receiving no treatment of any kind
in order to compare people receiving no
treatment people who think they're
getting homeopathy but are getting
SIBO and people who think they are
getting homeopathy and are getting
homeopathy there's a 1997 paper
published in The Lancet which looked at
186 clinical trials testing homeopathy
and stated in its conclusion that quote
we found insufficient evidence from
these studies that homeopathy is clearly
efficacious for any single clinical
condition there are many of these in
2002 the british journal of clinical
pharmacology published a huge
meta-analysis of controlled clinical
trials of homeopathy and it concluded
that scientific affirmations of
homeopathy are due to biases by the
publication's themselves another
comprehensive study finished in 2014
which led the Australian Department of
Health to study homeopathy effectiveness
in treating 68 different medical
conditions the review concluded that
homeopathy had no positive effect on any
of the conditions including asthma
arthritis insomnia the flu eczema
cholera burns heroin addiction and many
many others there's another study led by
the Australian Department of Health
finished in 2015 which reviewed 1,800
other studies and confirmed once again
that there is quote no good quality
evidence to support the claim that
homeopathy is effective in treating
health conditions homeopathy advocacy
groups are famous for lying misusing
data and taking scientific findings
about homeopathy completely out of
context in 2010 in a statement to the UK
Parliament the British homeopathic
Association quoted a 2000 study in the
European Journal of clinical
pharmacology as saying quote there is
some evidence that homeopathic
treatments are more effective than
placebo but the British homeopathic
Association left off the rest of the
quote which says however the strength of
this evidence is low because of the low
methodological quality of the trials
studies of high methodological quality
were more likely to be negative than the
lower quality studies as is the case
with other types of alternative medicine
and health-related pseudo-sciences
a fear of evidence-based pharmacology is
motivating many people's inclinations to
practice receive and defend homeopathy
it's a folk tradition that runs in many
families and some people just don't like
the idea of taking pharmaceutical drugs
for a range of reasons that are
sometimes irrational according to the
National Institutes of Health over 6
million people in the u.s. use
homeopathy frightening ly enough about 1
million of those people are children
being administered homeopathy by their
parents homeopathy really is a special
kind of pseudoscience in that it
actually manages to have multiple layers
of BS that are scientifically unsound in
completely unrelated ways homeopathy
ascribes false healing powers to various
substances like saying duck liver treats
the flu or venom from honeybees can
treat allergic reactions to bee stings
but then homeopathy also goes on to say
that the more diluted of substances the
more potent it becomes which flies
directly in the face of everything we
know about the science of pharmacology
and then homeopathy goes as far as
pretending to defy the basics of
physical chemistry by saying that
solvents diluting substances ad nauseam
are even capable of retaining remnants
of that substance through this memory
that they claim exists for which there
is absolutely no evidence and then of
course put all of that aside scientific
studies have Illustrated that
homeopathic treatments aren't medically
effective but the homeopathy has already
shown us that they aren't too fazed by
what science says but I know that you
probably value science and reason which
is why you should go check out class
central.com slash Pakman click the link
in the description to start searching
for top-rated college lectures from
world-renowned universities on almost
any topic you can think of class central
offers tens of thousands of University
courses on business science math
computer programming politics economics
you name it and many of those courses
are completely free check it out at
class
- central.com / Pakman that's PA que ma
n or just click the link under this
video